[Music]
there's a pennsylvania home that
recently went on the market for about
300k it comes with three oceans
[Laughter]
three of them atlantic pacific and
indian no mediterranean actually no
daniel oceans oh
he's sexy
who's dan let's talk about that for ten
minutes frank ocean
oh that's jorge clooney all right top
three oceans everyone right now frank
ocean daniel ocean indian ocean
that's pretty good have you been to the
indian one that's pretty good flew over
it
i want to go to indian though it must
have been a really good time you had
he's a top ocean i like i like franco
billy ocean no one's that old anymore
what's the ocean uh
where uh indonesia is is that the
pacific oh could you talk about bali
yeah that's a great ocean good ocean
nice warm one or is that a c i don't
[ __ ] know okay nobody knows the
answer actually oh so pennsylvania huh
yeah so it isn't oceans what special
feature do you think this house has
that makes it worth 300k because the
average home because average home is
what like 60 grand or something uh they
are pretty cheap but uh not that this
thing particularly makes the value go up
but there's a very stand out feature it
comes with a bengal tiger it has a moat
philly cheese steak maker
like a guy hey anytime you want it i'm
in here
he says that all the time
any guesses a giant marble bathroom with
a tub and a fountain in it that's like
unnecessarily gaudy has a taco bell in
it that'd be sick yeah a cantina though
talk about cancer what celebrity has a
taco bell in their house and richie rich
from the movie
he had a mcdonald's right richie rich
for the movie
oil digging thing the thing is
so far uh steve's the closest because no
i'm gonna keep guessing what do you say
what'd you say amando's they got a
nando's in there what'd you say that was
so cool he said taco bell it's a sonics
uh no it's actually it's it's not that
he's close because of naming taco bell
but he's close that you could
potentially put one in there because
look what this house has
let's let's take a little home tour
shall we right imagine this is the house
you just bought yeah okay well that's a
nice room right
not bad not bad so far come on
homeowners you guys the only ones that
would really 300 grand
that's a [ __ ] dream dude well how
come the other house had it was just
green grass wow that's a nice bathroom
yeah
here we go what's that little wood guy
over there on the left oh it's a tunnel
oh a secret door anything with a red
circle around it you know it's gonna be
good i'm probably gonna click on that
there's a secret passageway is it ghost
in there so
oh it's a wine cellar
it goes into a strange little cave a sex
dungeon that goes that far deep
and has stairs going down into more
caves no ways this is a bad cave did
they make a bad cave down there if they
have a [ __ ] bat cave i will move
there i can buy this house right now
i'll bob i'll move there sell your [ __ ]
300 geez it goes even further down
and then that is the end of the cave oh
that's that's not quite the bad
aka where the taco bell begins
[Laughter]
underground taco bell experience
isn't that that's pretty [ __ ] rad
right
it like goes into the into the mountain
it's built against and like it's yeah
that thing was built so it's not a
natural cave so you're putting [ __ ]
monitors down there getting your little
batcave situation going on then yeah but
don't you think like the the service
would be really difficult you know what
i mean
that looks like a dungeon just you could
just optic it all the way in i'm just
trying to be realistic here okay just
pull the line the fiber optic line is
telling your brain some of us aren't as
privileged okay you go to a [ __ ] a
best buy and you buy like a hundred feet
of cable for like 25 bucks
and a bunch of extension cords and then
you go
and what you do is you tell your wife
don't go in there that's my jerk room
[Laughter]
that's good wives never respect the jerk
they don't respect the jerk room they
don't even let you have one it's like
even mentioning it just fantasy wise
what are you guys really putting down
okay there are we putting in the cave
the arcade okay that's it you gotta go
that far just to [ __ ] play neal i put
my crypto battle station down there i
probably put a bunch of [ __ ] little
ant miners because probably nice and
cool in there but will it reach because
of service
antennas on top what do you put back
there bart i don't know
yeah
you're a lamb
looks pretty big i mean uh mirrors
probably a few love sacks
looks like a good love sack ideally what
i would want is
i think a bat cave
my ideal bat cave needs another exit
in case i need to sneak out in the
middle of night to get krispy kremes
well you just better keep on digging so
that's why so what i would do to expand
on expand on the batcave and then drill
a little hole somewhere else hopefully i
can find an exercise a little trap door
i'm going to buy a batmobile you guys
are going to see you guys will see and
when i do step two will be something
like that which batmobile you're going
to get 19 19 batman 100 that's the best
one for sure hands down i thought plus
it's got the little wheel ball that
comes out into a bomb
i heard the new one is actually sick
because it's something that you could
actually just own and drive the robert
pattinson looks like a mustang yeah it
looks like um a challenger kind of
that's what they told me i still like
the keaton one better yeah he was the
best one how are you gonna drive on
[ __ ] atlantic
dude you just don't drive honestly like
[ __ ] you just don't drive there you got
a batmobile you're not going to take it
to monterey imagine trying to [ __ ]
like
park the batmobile yeah like
forget it or even in l.a wrong shape
yeah
so this place eliminates itself as a bat
cave because there's no exit
what else could it be it'd be really
inconvenient but it would be sick to
have like an illuminated giant fish tank
down there oh
i saw a fish tank for piranha flipping
i one time out of business me [ __ ]
looking at houses i saw a fish tank bar
and it was like sick that's [ __ ] sick
no one's got any evil ideas or something
like this
all these ideas
like obviously you have like bdsm [ __ ] i
think that's where most people's minds
were going because they still don't know
what it used to be
it looks like a wine cellar no because
unlike what they say on the jk news
reddit i'm not my evil
[Laughter]
bart admits to being pure evil
indirectly but we are [ __ ] though
[Laughter]
we're not evil but we [ __ ] yeah
so they're right some of the time
looks like it looks like it could be a
bunker as well okay there you go that's
a nice thing in case there's like some
kind of a missile attack or something
yeah yeah you should also keep like your
you know weapons and [ __ ] there
preppers would love this [ __ ] but
preppers love this crappers twinkies and
ding dongs and [ __ ]
yeah things that last forever zombie
apocalypse you up but it does suck that
there is no alternate exit i mean that
is kind of wow was there not two wooden
things or is just one way in one way in
and then you just dead end at like a you
know what about you booby trap it you
[ __ ] indiana jones style booby traps
so that you're always constantly in
china yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know what i mean the giant rock just in
case you know what you mean someone
chases you down there that's your panic
room
i have a use for it what i would do
is
i would take the stairs out make it nice
and smooth slide no no buy the highest
quality water i could find
dump it in there and then get throw a
pail so that way i have my own well
and so i'll make it hard but it's still
high quality like fiji water that's a
quality that's a bar idea and that one
when i'm thirsty i go
gia i'm so thirsty because i have some
water and she has to get it from the
well she reaches for the fridge and
you're trying to take this back to the
nile river you're trying to have her go
pale water for you when you're thirsty
you were getting close to a good idea
i think i think like the youtube channel
me and joe watch where these these dudes
like hike out in the jungle and they
[ __ ] start building like a little
kicking at things making water
vietnamese guys those dudes are [ __ ]
the best you watch them in like 3x speed
yeah they build like this little temple
and they fill it with water and they
[ __ ] start swimming all around it
that's what you do in there i'm going to
swim around
see these videos can you just send it to
the group chat because i want to see
what these videos are they don't pop up
on your feed
i feel like everyone has seen this like
primitive technology i don't get that my
algorithm is very different anytime i'm
on youtube or like tick tock we'll stop
looking up men's butts
it's for my job it's part of my work
there's butts in these videos we're
talking about you're always getting the
top 10 grapplers getting lost in the
passion
top 10 grapplers who got lost
in each other's eyes while tussling
double leg to a [ __ ]
i love ryan asking nick that's outside
all serious and stuff just like hey when
you ever like get into the the depth of
grappling do you ever get like lost in
the passion
where you're like [ __ ] it let's just
kiss i asked him that outside or you go
what was your question that you would
ask me like as we're grappling and then
the other guy goes i was like are you
feeling this too
just getting hot are you feeling what
i'm feeling i want to know if that ever
really happens you get really close and
you're like like when you're both in the
zone yeah when you're both in the zone
and then one guy just kind of like you
know that's what it looks like
fighting anybody in my opinion
shit's [ __ ] hilarious dude i watched
him against like who who's that guy
everyone talks about like gracie
the dude those guys want to [ __ ] so bad
that's the whole thing they keep
fighting each other they just can't get
out of their system they see the
opponent
yes
oh he's in my bracket yeah
would this would this be a nice place to
do your personal training yeah that'd be
cool yeah but you know at the same time
it's like i'd rather save that for some
other cool [ __ ] like you know
you don't be sick for that actually
[ __ ] illegal majung like betting
asian moms love that you guys want to
play mj yeah
you play yeah i mean i'm not great but
yeah i'm not great either but you guys
want to read chinese dude that game is
pretty weird i know but you could
remember just a question chinese [ __ ] on
that thing it's easy though do they
match or not some of them are like
numbers too where like you know you can
see the one two and three we should all
play mj that's fun bro there's one man
in this room who hasn't spoken up about
what he would do with this cave and it's
the most joe thing i've ever heard about
what the [ __ ] would you do with it oh
man a [ __ ] backs back there you know
what i mean
oh dude all i could think about is like
uh like a torture dungeon yeah like
something fun you know like a torture
dungeon oh dude i'd have all the best
medieval equipment in there to throw
some people that i just want to people
that wrong [ __ ] up yeah dude like the
stretcher [ __ ] enemies enemies enemies
people that [ __ ] you over people in my
past people in my present man they're
gonna get [ __ ] oh man they're getting
tortured so
[Laughter]
you won't see me for a week
well yeah have you ever heard the
neighbors app where like you store
things for other neighbors in your
garage and they pay you oh yeah like
don't you like parking their yacht on
your [ __ ] garage or some [ __ ] yeah i
think you could turn this cave into that
but only for like disposing dead bodies
oh yeah because it's harder to find dead
bodies than someone else's residence
like they hardly ever check you see
those people that make dungeons with
their [ __ ]
prisoners in there no one knows for 20
years like that should be perfect
what's the last guy do with it it looks
like he just left it there they don't
know that's the crazy thing like uh the
last time this house went for sale was
1998 how much do you think it sold for
in 98 50 000. this is 300k today how
many square feet a hundred thousand
a hundred thousand fifty seven thousand
dollars it is i think the total square
foot is twenty one hundred oh okay for
the property fifty grand yeah wow 58
grand oh yeah 50 58 000.
you're a human zillow now he gets it
first oh sorry you're the closest to my
best but that was a better guess that
was great bart that was so good that was
such a good guess
i totally overlooked anthony's cat
thanks to bart
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you